[Music]
eric palacios and associates the
sponsors of this next segment want to
remind you how important it is to
understand how wills and trust work for
your family i spoke to attorney michael
ortiz to learn more
michael welcome back to the show thank
you thank you for having us
unfortunately wills and trust it's a sad
topic but we have to talk about it
people need to know what's how they can
do this so if someone doesn't have a
will you know where do their belongings
go
yes if you die with our will or
intestate as it is called your estate
your things your belongings they go to
your spouse
if you have kids and a spouse then half
goes to your spouse and half goes to
your kids
uh if you don't have a spouse your kids
would inherit everything but if you
don't have a spouse or children then
your parents would inherit everything
what is a living trust
yes uh a living trust is a document an
instrument that's even better than it
will
and that's because it allows you to your
heirs to inherit uh things seamlessly
without the process of probate and
without an inheritance tax
and what's the cost of a will and a
trust how much does this cost families
uh it depends obviously on uh your needs
but generally a will will run you
between 200 to 500
uh versus a
a trust which can cost between a
thousand to twenty five hundred dollars
okay and when should someone start
thinking about a will or when should
they actually get one
most people will wait until they're well
in their 50s okay but i would say that
this is a huge mistake as soon as you
purchase a home or you get married you
should really think about your plans and
skates in case something does happen to
you it's always best to be prepared
all right good advice thank you so much
michael
thank you for having us
thank you eric palacios and associates
for sponsoring this segment for more
information give them a call at
702-444-7777